let's go next to
DeSean from Atlanta Georgia DeSean
welcome to the program
DeSean please
hi hello hello
how are you doing today I'm doing well
good good
um I had two quick questions for you
sure
um so one uh how is your field or
outlook on that kid that got sent home
for having a shirt that said there's
only two genders I don't know where that
happened where did that happen it was it
I I don't know I I saw on Instagram some
some kid he he wore a shirt to school
and people were saying that they felt
unsafe and that he was he was being like
a distraction or something what what's
your opinion so here it is seventh
grader sent home for wearing t-shirt
that said there are only two genders
this is a 12 year old and
um we don't have to say the kid's name
was removed from gym class and told to
take off his shirt because people were
complaining it was making them feel
unsafe he refused they called his father
his father ended up having to pick him
up
um
listen I I don't I don't know how I feel
about this you know on the one hand how
involved do we want to get in how kids
dress at public schools with no dress
code obviously they can't wear things
that are obscene I guess would be the
law the question is is that an obscene
shirt
uh I agree that it could be a shirt that
is deeply a troubling and offensive to
people is it obscene I don't know so I'm
not sure about the legal basis wait wait
wait I I have a question how what's
what's uh what's what's what's the
what's the problem with it though you
said that you said that there was
something wrong with wearing well in
that it's not that I said that there's
something wrong but like let I'll give
you a scenario right imagine that you
are a trans person right you were you're
biologically male but you are trans you
identify as female and you are starting
to you know dress and Style Yourself the
way women traditionally do in modern
society I could see how seeing that
shirt is going to cause you uh Stress
and Anxiety and potentially make you
feel unsafe because it's a very like
listen I'll give you an opinion I mean
he he got sent us he got sent home for
wearing a t-shirt that says fact well
hold on a second I can't you can't
nothing wrong with that that's just his
that's just his you know what I'm saying
hold on a second Sean but let's wait a
second right let's just wait a second
hold on to Sean your switch you're
you're jumping between saying the shirt
is a fact versus people's rights let's
pick one of these things to focus on
right because you're jumping all around
all right let's
let's all right so let's let's just
let's just put this a scenario okay yeah
let's say I go to school and and I go to
school and it says I'll wear a shirt
that says there's only boy and girl
all right what tell me if tell me if
that's a legitimate reason for me to get
sent home
yeah I'm I'm I don't know that it is a
legitimate reason to be sent home it
doesn't be like well hold up DeSean
you're not even letting me talk though
now I'm letting you talk bro but I'm
just I'm just trying to get you know
what I'm saying no but every three words
you're interrupting me here's the the
thing I'm struggling with uh I am close
to a free speech absolutist in that I
really don't want to be restricting the
speech of individuals unless there's
like a very clear reason to do so and
when we talk about clothes being worn in
school my tendency would be to say let's
let's not get involved in schools making
those decisions I'm thinking of let's
just think about another shirt that
someone could wear right like I'm a
Jewish person imagine that I'm 12 and
someone wears a shirt to school that
says all non-christians are going to
hell it's certainly not an illegal shirt
but as a Jewish person I'm gonna see
that and say wow that's a lot of damn
hostility towards me based on my
identity does this person know my
Identity or not am I safe is this going
to be a comfortable learning environment
so you know Deshawn if you listen to my
show you know I'm not big on trigger
warnings or any of this college being a
safe space thing but I'm struggling with
what should be allowed in a middle
school for shirts I don't know the
answer
all right I mean that that's that's a
reasonable that's a reasonable answer
would you can I ask you a question
Desean
oh yes sir go ahead yo I mean I thought
I was asking a question but yeah go
ahead well you know we can both ask
questions that's the beautiful thing
about Independent Media
um would you agree separate now from
biological sex do you agree that people
Express gender on a spectrum I'm not
asking your opinion of whether it's good
or bad do you just agree that people
Express their gender I agree I agree
that if you have a certain belief of
biology and your science stands on it
and you have that sort of belief then
you can stand by it you can stand by
what
on biology no but let me ask you look
can I rephrase the questions you can't
because there ain't no Spectrum on on
biology I'm not that wasn't my question
Sean is it okay if I just restate my
question a different way and then you
can answer it or not
okay but I have a second question that I
I didn't I didn't ask it because let's
get to that in a second let me just
first just to make me feel good flatter
me let me ask my question one more time
okay
colliding you what what you mean by that
bro okay
okay go ahead indulge is maybe what I
mean would you agree that The Rock
Dwayne The Rock Johnson and the fashion
designer Isaac Mizrahi are both
biologically male would you agree with
that
I mean the rock is a man and whoever I
don't know the other person but if
they're a God then yeah then they're a
man okay would you also agree that
despite both being biological men they
express their gender very differently
where the rock expresses significantly
more masculinity while Isaac Mizrahi
expresses more what we might associate
with femininity would you agree with
that
yeah okay yes yes but but listen
the difference between expressing and
what you are but I'm all I'm asking you
is you can you can express yourself all
you want see the rock can express itself
as as uh a dress wearing yes
now that you're swearing we're gonna
have to bleep so we can't just please
don't all I'm saying to Sean is all I'm
saying is my question was do you agree
do you agree that gender is expressed on
a spectrum and you agreed with the
example I just gave that that's true I'm
not pushing any other belief on you
other than that
well what's your what's your idea on a
spectrum though I don't understand that
biological Men Express different levels
of masculinity and femininity in their
expression and so do biological women
that's all that's all I'm saying you
agree that gender is expressed on a
spectrum
well people Express their gender in
different ways I mean you can say you
can say you're a man but then on the
other hand you can act like you're like
you're not a man you know what I'm
saying all right I think I got it all
right real quick what was your other
question Desean
and um oh yeah this was this was
actually a very very important question
okay
what do you think about
women
trans women going into sports playing
against other women
okay I've addressed this a thousand
times I think in a lot of sports it
doesn't matter I think we do need to
figure out does not matter well there
are certain Sports where physical
strength is not the uh sort of
determining factor of Advantage but I
agree that we need to figure out in
certain Sports how to handle that I
don't know the answer I think it's a
tough question and I don't have an
answer I think it does have to be
figured out it that it is it is actually
because you know how there's the WNBA
and there's the NBA like there's there's
a reason yeah but I'd agree with you
DeSean I'd agree with you on basketball
branches I'm agreeing with you on
basketball I would agree with you I
don't I don't know what we do it seems
we need to figure that out so is it is
it now is it now that we have to make a
transport sort of League thing like is
this what we're gonna have to do like
you understand what I'm saying I do
that's an idea
manhandling women you know what I'm
saying that's just ridiculous all right
DeSean thank you so much there's DeSean
from Atlanta he's acting like my views
on these issues are totally different
from what they are like yeah we got to
figure that out I mean in some sports
I'm not sure what you do we've talked
about do you have to look at
um does there have to be some medical
consensus about whether I don't know in
some sports what we do I'm not
pretending that we've solved that uh so
there's no reason to you know put
pretend like my view is something other
than what it is